what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so it's no secret that I love old
man Logan I love the old man Logan
source I wish they were not released
monthly because we had away two months
to cover this story I really wish that
be that Marvel did not release their
comics monthly I wish they were
releasing them bi-weekly but they're not
so they just kind of have to work within
the confines of what we have but this is
Jeff Lemire really just kind of going
back through and saying here is how we
get into the story or how we get to the
point where old man Logan relive all of
his old experiences now this is really
kind of cool because this is designed or
at least the upcoming story is designed
to be Jeff Lemire swan song for old man
Logan we know he's leaving activist this
particular bit is over and so it's going
to be sad to see him go but it's been
one hell of a ride and I consider this
some of the best Wolverine riding of all
time and that's why I have a playlist
for old man Logan and all-new Wolverine
so that we can go through and you can we
can literally start with the origin of
x-23 and we can work our way forward and
just see some incredible storytelling
with with the old man Logan line of
stories and even the yellow the x-23
line of stories but the back your names
here this comes out of the last story
that we went over called return to the
wasteland and remember return to the
wasteland basically dealt with the idea
they're all mental Odin was kind of
experiencing this jump between the
reality he hailed from the wastelands a
university hailed from with the modern
day and so he didn't know if what he was
seeing was real or an illusion now by
the time it was all said and done it was
basically shown to us that it was an
illusion that was cast by Jean Grey who
was basically been taken over by the
brood a spacefaring race that was
looking to usurp Jean Grey into their
ranks and make her one of their own but
with these different visions that Jean
Grey had put in the mind of Logan for
the purpose just kind of torturing his
sanity what it did is it forced him to
ask the question what happened to Bruce
Banner jr. now this requires us to jump
back a little bit so for those of you
guys who are familiar who've been
following along the way bear with me for
a second living the original old man
Logan's store and we don't need to
rehash the whole thing the story's down
in the description but in the original
old man Logan story after Logan and
basically killed Bruce Banner he had
killed she-hulk he had killed all the
members of the banner family and
eventually basically took Bruce Banner
jr. as his own he just kind of ridden
off into the sunset this was followed up
in both
the Saugus but the secret was old man
Logan's high-end and all-new
all-different marbles old man Logan will
basically learn that Logan himself had
left Bruce Banner jr. with Daniel Cage
the daughter of Jessica Jones and Luke
Cage both of whom had died during the
during the whole event but the night the
superheros died when almost superheroes
across the world were killed by the
villains and so what descends up doing
here is it begs the question what
happened to Bruce Banner jr. one of the
illusions that that old man Logan had
had was that Bruce Banner Jr basically
went on to become a warlord he went on
to become as kind of a tyrant or he was
like the newest iteration of the maestro
now we know just by virtue of Jonathan
Hickman's fantastic Fork the most likely
future to unfold is that Bruce Banner
jr. is going to usher in a new age of
superheroes who are going to basically
destroy Galactus and then use his body
as a way to you know jump back into the
past some of the cause of the fact of
the earth is on the verge of destruction
because the earth is kind of coming to
an end the planet's approaching its
twilight so because of that we know
that's the future that's most likely
going to happen but the question that's
being asked here is what if that future
doesn't happen
what if Bruce Banner jr. becomes a
warlord and rules the earth and so the
goal of Logan is to travel into the past
to figure out what happened to Bruce
Banner jr. and try to guide him in the
right direction now this will likely
culminate in Bruce Banner jr. being
brought back to the modern day I really
have no idea where we'll go from there
but the entire Vinh here is basically
having Logan right into the cell now the
seller is one of a multitude of
different prisons that exist across
Marvel Comics and a lot of these are
designed for the purpose of housing
individuals who are extremely powerful
some are more powerful than others so
like the raft is designed to house
people who are pretty powerful this
seller is for people who are insanely
powerful so again it's really like
different locations for different levels
now there are some people who just
deserve a more personal touch you know
for example danos because Thanos is so
dangerous because he's so intelligent
and because he's so capable he was held
within the Triskelion the home base of
the ultimate so they could keep a
personal eye on him and make sure he
didn't escape just because if he did he
wouldn't lay waste to the superheroes on
earth and so because of that god I love
banners but I loved a nose for that or
he just liked washes the world
superheroes almost every single time
they fight if they don't have anybody
would like insane powers in their side
like
strangers like that but the fact remains
here that that Logan is basically
breaking into the cellar now we don't
know why all we're given by Jeff Lemire
are these sort of jump backs and we pick
up like nine days before all this
happened with Illyana Rasputin now in my
mind this is how you use characters who
are really powerful you basically have
them turn down sonar yes and I don't
know kind of seems like a caveat like
what why would you do that why would you
want to invoke a super-powerful
character only to get rid of them the
reason why is because it makes practical
sense what Jeff Lemire does is he
basically has Logan approach Illyana
Rasputin to the younger sister of
Colossus who goes by the name of magic
now in the Autorama Sweden has the
ability to manipulate all kinds of
dimensional and magical energies she's
extremely powerful but her bread and
butter is basically interdimensional and
time travel and so because of this what
happens because Logan basically says
look I need you to send me to the future
to find out what happened to Bruce
Banner jr. now this is the funny thing
about this and this is what I like about
what Jeff Lemire is doing here Jeff
Lemire basically establishes where the
waste lands that dystopian future
resides within the realm of all-new
all-different marvel what happens is
Illyana Rasputin that says basically
it's not as simple as sending you into
the future because we don't know that is
the future all we know is that you just
came from a place where a dystopian
future occurred the Knights of all the
superheroes died but things are changing
all around us because we know that
within a few years that was supposed to
happen but we don't know if it will
happen and in fact if you go and look up
the old man Logan universe you know in
any comic or any story we'll know that
it's an alternate reality it's an
alternate universe and so what Illyana
Rasputin basically says is what you're
talking about is traversing going into
the future of another dimension and so
again it's really kind of a funny
situation because it's like Oh what
happens if you get there and it's
nothing like what you remember it being
you know what happens if we send you to
the wrong one there's any number of
things that can go wrong here you're not
walking to the house next door you're
just putting a blindfold on and then
walking to a house that's five blocks
down and to the left there's no
guarantee you'll even get there and so
the idea here is that is that really she
just kind of shoots them down and says
no I'm not going to do this I'm not
going to send you back to the wasteland
you've grown you've changed you're not
who you used to be do not go back there
and torture yourself and so that's the
reason why he's here is because you
basically at this at this
Celer trying to find someone who can
send him back through Todd now the funny
thing about this is along the way he
encounters Miles Morales now we're not
told how Maas well it's got here we're
not told why he's the only one here and
in truth it doesn't really I mean it's
not significant it doesn't really matter
it's cool to see them fight and that's
all that I care it's cool to see old man
Logan faced off against Miles Morales
because it is it's two characters who
would normally never never meet fighting
one another and that's kind of a funny
thing here is because of the fact that
no one is familiar with old man Logan de
Familia with Wolverine but they're not
familiar with old man Logan now I would
like to believe that a Peter Parker just
kind of came walking in and saw Miles
Morales fighting old man Levin he'll
just be like what are you doing this
guy's way beyond you like you're nowhere
near where you need to be in order to
face off against old man Logan and
that's true like oh man Logan's got
experience he's a little bit slower you
but what he lacks in speed he makes up
for in experience and Miles Morales does
not have the ability to take on old man
Logan he doesn't have the strength the
combat experience doesn't work old man
Logan's got a healing factor he's got
adamantium bones not really super
strength per se but he's stronger than
your average bear so because that he is
a force to be reckoned with especially
because of the fact that if he chose to
push it to the max he'd be fighting to
kill in Miles Morales would not survive
the experience and this is shown by the
fact that he's able to basically
overcome every single attempt that Myles
makes and trying to stop him whether
it's you know shooting webs at his feet
grab his hands and letting whatever the
case may be he breaks free every single
time and this is when we actually follow
him through a multitude of different
people he went to go see beasts he went
to go see shaman someone of Native
American heritage who deals with deals
with magic he went to go see cable The
Scarlet Witch Doctor Doom black panther
you know all these different guys and
they all said no now the real kicker to
this is Doctor Strange and that's kind
of a funny thing about this is because
Doctor Strange meddled with time all the
time but he's immensely he metals of
time a lot he travels to other
dimensions a lot he messes with magic
and stuff and thought it's also kind of
Jeff Lemire hitting on the point of the
original age of Ultron event because
remember when age of Ultron first
dropped when that story came to a
conclusion one of the things that Bendis
established is that time is not just a
thing you know time is not something you
can just mess what time is a living
organism
more you manipulated the more you bend
it and the more you bend it the closer
it will come to breaking and if it
breaks it'll send ripples throughout all
things in existence
that's how mar will justify the the
beginning of the collapse of the
universe by virtue of dr. Doom's actions
and so on and so forth but it was
basically sending shockwaves all
throughout the the entire multiverse
which allowed Galactus from the main
Marvel Universe to end up in the
ultimate universe it just had all these
different things going on and what's
hard you know we talked about that
during our whole superior spider-man run
but the fact remains here that with old
man Logan facing off against Myles what
he needs is a distraction so he
basically just frees a whole bunch of
the whole works of the guys now in truth
he probably could have taken him out I
would say within the confines of this
story Miles Morales is really more of a
nuisance as opposed to somebody to
actually face off against now this also
provides a little bit of growth a little
bit of growing room because we could
turn around and see you know this event
reference most likely in the mile as
well as comics of those it's written by
Bendis so you're probably just kind of
ignore continuity we could see this
reference in the miles where I was
saying hey look I learned a lot from my
fight what old man look what we end up
finding out is that Logan being here is
designed for the purpose of tracking
down a guy named Osmo Diaz now Osmo Dias
is man he's an old-school villain man if
that's really reaching back but he was a
minor guy at best but Osmo Dias is a guy
by the name of Benton and he's actually
somebody who's sold his soul through a
guy named Stu tannish now was in the
realm of marvel comics there's all kinds
of demons right like Mephisto is at the
top of all the demons that exist he's
effectively the devil he's basically
Satan in the realm of Marvel Comics and
so because of that he's extremely
powerful in terms of his abilities I
would say that he's probably up there
with some of the most powerful cosmic
entities if he's in his home dimension
if he's in the realm of Hell now if he
leaves hell his power will start to
dwindle the longer he stays away which
means he'll just start getting weaker
and weaker to the point that he could be
killed by some of the higher ranking
members of the Marvel Universe they
would take everything they have to do it
but it's Mephisto is out of his own
realm long enough it can probably happen
but with regards to Oz one day soon I'm
coming back to this guy he was he was
part of a group called the the cult of
satanic I think it was and they
basically sold their soul to satanic in
exchange for power
wonders of happening is awesome odious
actually took over as the leader of the
cult and it was eventually defeated and
captured by the Avengers and he's just
been there ever since
she's been in this prison ever since
then so it's really Jeff Lemire kind of
reaching out of nowhere to grab this guy
but what is up happening is old man
Logan basically free satanís gives him
his his wand
I'm sorry gives him his staff and his
cloak after which we learned that he had
actually stolen them from dr. dr.
Strange's home and then basically
engineers their escape for miles morales
and everybody else and so what ends up
happening here is a tannish basically
says I need some of your blood if we're
going to cut your if we're going to go
through with this I need some of your
blood what I'll do is I'll send your
mind into the body of your younger self
much like what we saw Claremont do which
Days of Future past and then we'll
follow the events of old man Logan
that's exactly what happens with Logan
being sent back into the body of his
younger self in his own dimension what
is up happening here is we actually jump
back to 1812 really to like the first
major event of his life when he was in
conflict you know and I guess when he'd
really come into his powers and began to
understand who he was and so because of
this what this does is it lays the
groundwork for the entire life of old
man Logan it follows his entire
existence as he goes from being you know
this guy that first learned about the
basis of his powers when he was younger
fighting in the war of 1812 presumably
up until the modern day in terms of
Wendie when the wastelands haven't
happened and how the different villains
took over the world and so God willing
we will actually see the entire event
unfold we will see the entire conflict
take place hopefully that's what happens
I have no idea but if you guys are new
here to come and explain make sure you
guys with the sub button to become part
of the rob Court if you guys enjoyed
this video make sure you drop a like and
yeah I will catch you guys later peace
[Music]
you